The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
for the rest of class,
I'm going to talk
about post-production.
Do you guys want to
take a five minute break
before I jump into that?
OK.
I will do that when
you guys come back.
All right, so last
lecture-- should I
stand up for this since I
stood for all the other ones?
OK.
Feel free to interrupt
me at anytime.
So I'm going to start off with
my favorite quote of all time,
at least for this class,
which is, "In writing,
you must kill all
your darlings."
And that is what today's
lecture is about.
Post-production 101 or
Killing All of Your Darlings.
So when we think of production,
we think of the journey
that we have taken in the
last week of this class.
We start with
ideation, we script,
we storyboard, shoot,
edit, and then we
get to this product magically.
And we have these three concrete
steps of pre-production,
production, which is
what you're about to do,
and post-production.
Let me know when I can
go to the next slide.
The reality is that it's
not like that at all.
And maybe you've seen that.
Hopefully, you've seen that in
the course in the last week--
that you don't do production
in this nice linear, sequential
format, but you
ideate and you script.
And when you script, you
go back to your idea.
When you're storyboarding, it
affects your original idea.
And that's how I'd like you guys
to approach editing as well.
At least, I used
to think of editing
as something that happened
after I shot everything.
And once I got to
editing, that was sort of
equivalent to just throwing
what you have together,
but that that's not
necessarily the case.
In post-production you're going
to find a lot of things that
maybe help you re-shoot things.
And thinking about
post-production
before you've even
started production
can help you think of ways to
shape what you're going to do.
So that is why I'm talking about
editing before you have even
started to film.
So when we think of
editing, we think
of taking or creating something
that is representative
of continuous time.
We think about putting
together a video that
has just the bad bits removed.
So has anyone done any
video editing whatsoever?
Kenneth, you have.
Yeah, so especially
with the webcam videos,
what you're basically doing is
recording a continuous event
and taking out the parts
where you mess up your line.
That's what we think of.
And we think of the bad
bits as being things
that maybe as a take that
was out of focus, maybe
your light was
overexposed, maybe
your delivery wasn't so good.
But in this simplest
sense, most people
think of editing as
presenting something
that is of continuous time.
But the problem is that
sometimes the bad bits are not
as obvious as things
like overexposed light,
and sometimes, you're
not necessarily
creating a product that
represents continuous time.
So I love this book.
It's on the syllabus.
It's written by the editor of
Godfather III, Apocalypse Now.
I think he did The
English Patient.
He did a bunch of movies that
won a lot of Academy Awards,
but he says that
editing is not so much a
putting together of a path, as
it is the discovery of one--
or something like that.
So the question is, how do
you best discover this path?
So the nice thing about
editing right now-- we're
in the digital age,
so we have the files
that we shot available to us in
these chunks and it's up to us
to tape pieces together.
But back when film
was actually on film,
you would have to
watch the entire reel
through to know exactly what
was on the physical tape itself,
which was very time
consuming, but it also
allowed you to see everything
in your fresh perspective
after you've shot it.
And I think that's
the first step
that you need to do when you
edit-- to review the pieces
that you've shot.
And I've mentioned this before
in one of the earlier lectures
I think, but after
you shoot, take a day
or take an afternoon.
Don't look at your
stuff unless you're just
checking to make sure
that all of the file's OK.
But when you sit down to
edit, I encourage everyone
to re-watch the
footage all over again
because when you're
shooting stuff,
or when you're
really tired and it's
been an entire day of
shooting, the way you
look at your footage may
be a little bit different.
So this is one of
the camera reports
from when we shot Lindsey's
video in D-Lab actually.
And I also encourage you
to do this while you're
shooting to keep
track of your files,
keep track of
what's a good take.
But then afterwards,
I would suggest
that you re-log everything.
And you don't necessarily have
to do it completely like this.
But this was a log that
I did after we shot Snot.
I could not review
the footage the day
of because I was so
exhausted so I looked
at it a couple days later.
And I was able to see
like, oh, you know,
this take wasn't really good
and it's not worth keeping.
And I'm not just saying
that because I'm tired.
So editing is really about
looking at the pieces
to see which ones
are worth keeping
and which ones are
not worth keeping.
But as I said, the
bad bits are not
necessarily as obvious as this
scene was really poorly lit.
Bless you.
What you're really
looking for are things
that don't advance the video.
And that is also not a
super tangible quality,
and I'm going to give you a
bunch of examples that will
hopefully help you understand
what is worth keeping and what
isn't.
But to understand
that, you have to ask
yourself the basic question--
why should I keep this scene?
And this is a very seemingly
stupid and inane question,
but I didn't ask myself that
the first couple videos that we
edited for Science
Out Loud and it
made for a very painful
editing experience.
So I'm going to
give you an example.
We shot a video on
how engines work--
and I showed you guys
clips of that earlier.
And we went out to a
horse farm in Acton.
And it was kind of a drive, and
it was a little bit complicated
to get all that
set up, so I really
wanted to get great footage
of the farm, and we did.
We got awesome footage of
Luke with one of the horses.
LUKE: We would need 230
horses, like AJ here,
to power our Cessna.
But we need 290,000 to
power our Boeing 777.
PROFESSOR: So it was
this really cool shot,
and it took us an
extra couple hours
to shoot with this horse, AJ.
And we were talking
about horsepower,
so that's why we had the visual.
But in the context
of the rough cut,
which I will show you
later on in this lecture--
it really didn't
make a lot of sense.
It was just like, we're
learning about engines,
and now here's all
this gratuitous B-roll
of a horse prancing around.
And I think that
I was really set
on keeping it because
I had remembered
how much extra time it took
us and how much extra planning
it took us.
But when you go to the
edit-- when you shoot,
you're going to
shoot like you're
going to keep everything.
And what Chris was saying
about take multiple angles,
take shots, take things that
you think you may not need.
But when you edit, you
have no ties to anything.
They are no longer
your darlings.
You can kill any
of them, and really
have a discerning eye for that.
So that's just quick
tip number one.
When you edit, try to
see what's on the screen
and not so much
the circumstances
in which you got the material.
So if you were really
tired that day,
don't think about
how much effort it
took for you to get that shot.
And I will admit that
I partially showed you
that because it broke my
heart to take that out
and I just feel like it needs
to see the light of day.
So like I said, most
people think about editing
as having a continuous linear
representation of an event.
This is what Slideshow does.
This is what
OpenCourseWare does.
Like these lecture videos--
when you watch them online,
it's pretty much start
to end, nothing too fancy
edited in between.
But remember that
there are lots of ways
that you can play with
this, either in the editing,
or in the scripting
and in the production.
So you have continuous linear.
Josh also talked about
this idea of In Medias
Res, which is starting
in the middle of things.
I think it's a hard concept
to really understand
so I'm going to show
you an example of it.
This is Lindsey's video
that we did in D-Lab.
And the way we start
it is with an opening
that we revisit halfway
through the video again.
LINDSEY: Corn husks burn
quickly and turn to ash.
These lumps burn hot like
firewood, longer than charcoal,
but are cleaner, greener,
and less expensive than both.
This is actually made from this,
and I'm going to show you how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
About 3 billion
people in the world
use charcoal today to heat
their homes and cook their food.
But charcoal can be expensive.
It produces a lot
of smoke when burned
and it's made from wood, which
contributes to deforestation.
In fact, 98% of Haiti's forests
have been cut down for fuel.
What we need is an
alternative fuel source.
Let's take a look at
how charcoal is made.
We have to first cut down
trees for wood, which we then
place in a closed vessel
and deprive of oxygen.
It carbonizes into charcoal
instead of burning to ash.
We then mix the charcoal
with a binding solution
and compress that into
lumps called briquettes.
This process creates
a fuel source that
works, but has its problems.
So let's hack the charcoal
production process to make
everything about it better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Part of what makes the charcoal
production process so expensive
is the equipment.
Instead of a fancy
vessel, you can
make a simple kiln
out of an oil drum
by cutting a large hole in the
top and several smaller ones
in the bottom.
Gather a couple large rocks
for the kiln to rest on,
a lid for the top, and you
have yourself a $15 kiln.
We also need some kind of tool
to mold the charcoal material
from the kiln into briquettes.
This is one of D Lab's earlier
designs for the hand press.
We pour a mixture of charcoal
and binder into the spout here,
hammer down the piston, slide
open the panel at the bottom,
and the briquette
pops right out.
This design costs about
$20 to manufacture,
but the engineers at
D-Lab wanted to do better.
They changed the
shape of the mold
into a square to make
it easier to manufacture
and significantly cut down on
the amount of material used.
This time, the mold itself is
used to scoop the charcoal.
Again, we hammer the piston.
And the briquette
pops right out.
This design is easy
to manufacture.
It creates briquettes faster
and it only costs about $2.00
to make.
Now that we've made the
equipment less expensive,
what can we do about
making the fuel cleaner?
If we can get all the smoke to
burn off while the charcoal is
being made instead
of being used,
we can decrease
the amount of smoke
released in people's homes.
Leaving the kiln open
for about five minutes
at the beginning of the
process will allow the smoke
to burn off outside.
So that's why we cut a hole
in the top of the oil drum.
All right, final challenge.
What can we do to make
this fuel more sustainable?
What if we replaced the
wood with something else?
Something like dried corn
husks, or dried corn puffs,
dried bean stocks, or
even dried banana peels?
These agricultural waste
products, or ag waste,
would normally be
discarded as trash.
But we can use them to
make charcoal-- and poof!
Your trash becomes
a precious resource.
And that's how you turn
trash into treasure.
Less expensive, cleaner burning,
more sustainable, treasure.
PROFESSOR: So in
watching this, it's
actually a little more
Bookend than In Medias Res,
but the concept is that you
open immediately with the thing
that you're not going to
talk about until later
on in the video.
And we could have opened
without her doing the,
this is actually made from this.
We could have just
opened with her at D-Lab
and it would've been fine.
It would've been the
continuous linear thing,
but we kind of
used it as a hook.
And I think a lot
of you are actually
going with this format of
starting in the action.
Julia's is kind of like this.
Let's see, who else
kind of has-- sort
of in the middle of things?
I think Paul's is a
little bit like this, too.
Just like you're in
the action immediately
without a bunch set up.
So that is one
way you can do it.
Again, this was a little
more of an example
of bookending stuff, too, which
is what Joshua's script does.
Kenneth, yours does
this right now, too.
Which is also a nice way to
encapsulate a video experience
in a tidy package.
So sort of opening the
same way you close.
For George's video on farts,
we did this quite literally.
We had him in the
exact same location
and set that we
opened the video with.
And that's how we did
my snot video as well.
You don't have to
do it that way,
but it's a very explicit way
of bookending your video.
GEORGE: You know
what's more like life
than a box of chocolates?
Farts.
You really never know
what you're going to get.
A skunk?
Rotten eggs?
PROFESSOR: And then-- oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
I wanted to skip to
the end of the video,
so let me just do
that really quickly.
So he opens in that location.
And then--
GEORGE: We're at
the very beginning
of understanding the incredible,
smellable science in your gut.
And until we do, happy farting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: So that's
just something
to think about if you're
getting ready to film
and you're deciding on the
location of where you're going
to open and close your video.
The other thing editing does
is it allows you to figure out
what's best to keep.
So this is an example of
where cutting out the bad bits
isn't as obvious for us.
In this section, it was
cutting out the bits
that don't work the best.
So I showed you
guys this before,
but basically taking stills
of all of your scenes.
And then seeing the shots in
the context of everything else
can help during editing as well.
The next concept I
wanted to talk about,
which is also in
Walter Murch's book--
is the idea of referred pain
when you're at the doctor.
You go to the doctor and
you have shoulder pain--
or like elbow pain.
And if your doctor
says, OK, we're
going to go in and
operate on your elbow,
then you should leave because
maybe this person is not
very good doctor.
What a good doctor
would do is ask you
about what kinds of
activities you've been doing.
He or she would check out
the rest of your body,
and then maybe find out that
the problem isn't your elbow,
but the problem is a pinched
nerve somewhere upstream.
So this is the analogy he makes.
Same thing with your videos.
If you're finding that
there's a certain scene that's
not working, most
of the time it will
be because you need
to change that scene.
But a lot of times, it may
be because you've set it up
in not the greatest way.
Or maybe the scenes preceding
it don't make a lot of sense.
So I will show you
an example of this.
And this is super,
super nuanced,
and it might just be because
we were being super nit-picky
and getting really OCD about it.
But this is a scene from the
fifth draft of Jamie's video.
JAMIE: This Digi-Comp
has 31 switches
and can count up to 127.
But modern computer chips
have over a billion switches.
They're made from wafers,
such as this one, where
each square represents a chip.
They're made from semiconductor
switches called transistors,
which have the advantage
of being solid state,
meaning they have
no moving parts.
This allows engineers, like me,
to make them smaller, faster,
and more energy efficient.
We can make them
over a billion times
faster than the Digi-Comp.
These semiconductor
switches make
modern electronics possible.
PROFESSOR: So the whole
video is about how
big, complicated
machines, like computers,
are built out of actually very
simple parts, like a switch.
And so the majority of his
video is with the Digi-Comp.
And he's talking about how
the switches are calculating
in binary, and then at
the very end of the video,
he goes, these switches are
what make modern electronics
possible, which is
true and it ties it
into the bigger context.
But when we were watching
the rough cut, our editor
[INAUDIBLE] and
George and I were
all like-- we felt like
the ending came super
abruptly and seemed
a little bit random--
that we're talking about
basic switches the whole video
and then all of a sudden,
he's like, and that's
what makes things possible.
So we thought about
re-recording the end,
but then we realized--
and again, maybe this
is a personal taste thing.
Maybe this video isn't actually
super different from the one
we ended up
publishing, but this is
an example of us troubleshooting
by looking at previous scenes
and how we set up
the final shot.
And we felt that the
gap between him talking
about semiconductors, and
then his final sentence
was a little bit too short.
So we thought maybe we could
make the pause a little bit
longer to signify that his final
shot is the encompassing idea.
So that's what we did.
JAMIE: Big the numbers can be.
This Digi-Comp has 31 switches
and can count up to 127.
But modern computer chips
have over a billion switches.
They're made from wafers,
such as this one where
each square represents a chip.
They're made from semiconductor
switches called transistors,
which have the advantage
of being solid state,
meaning they have
no moving parts.
This allows engineers, like me,
to make them smaller, faster,
and more energy efficient.
We can make them
over a billion times
faster than the Digi-Comp.
These semiconductor
switches make
modern electronics possible.
PROFESSOR: I mean, it's a
super, super nuanced thing.
I'm not sure if you
guys noticed it,
or even if it was
worth us doing.
But I wanted to show it as an
example of the thought process
that we had in troubleshooting
the final scene.
And I think it makes
a little more sense
in the context of
watching the entire video,
but in the interest
of time, I didn't
want to show you 10
minutes of the same video.
Edits can change a
lot more than just
taking out the bad, though.
They can completely
restructure things.
And I'll show you a little
bit from the rough cut
of the engines video.
Someone was asking exactly
what a rough cut should be--
if we need everything
in there, if we don't.
So this is an example of what
the first draft of a video
can look like.
We're missing a couple scenes.
A lot of things change.
ABHI: Hundreds of
years ago, James Watt
decided that my friend, Helga,
could lift 550 pounds a foot
in the air in one second.
And that's the definition
of a horsepower.
LUKE: This lawn mower
has 6 horsepower.
ABHI: This car has
110 horsepower.
LUKE: This Cessna
has 230 horsepower.
ABHI: And this jet
has 85,000 horsepower.
LUKE: But they do it
in different ways.
ABHI: A car uses
a piston engine.
This is a piston engine
that's been cut into a half
so you can look into it.
A mixture of fuel and air
enters through these valves
into this metal cylinder.
It's compressed when the
piston pushes up onto it,
and then this mixture is
burned through a spark plug,
causing the mixture to expand.
And the piston comes back down,
and this happens over and over
again.
There are multiple
pistons in a car,
and they're connected
through a series of linkages
to the wheel,
causing them to turn.
PROFESSOR: So I wanted
to show this example
to highlight that editing is
a super, super collaborative
process.
So after you guys put
together your rough cuts
and we screen-- for the
second half of that class,
we'll randomly assign
you editing partners.
And they're going to
look through your video
and annotate on a live
software that we have at MITx.
The editor who put
together that rough cut
did not hate that
font as much as I did.
And she did not hate that
music as much as I did.
All right, so if you're the only
person looking at your video--
to this person, maybe they
really liked the style,
they like the pacing of it.
But to me, and to George, and to
the second editor that we had,
we often have multiple editors
look through our stuff,
even if one person's the
main one doing the editing.
You get feedback that you
otherwise wouldn't have,
which is a very
obvious statement,
but I want you to see how
much it changed by the end.
I'll show you the opening again.
ABHI: Hundreds of
years ago, James Watt
decided that my friend, Helga,
could lift 550 pounds a foot
in the air in one second.
And that's the definition
of a horsepower.
LUKE: This lawn mower
has 6 horsepower.
ABHI: This car has
130 horsepower.
LUKE: This Cessna
has 230 horsepower.
ABHI: And this jet
has 85,000 horsepower.
All of these engines
produce power
by forcing a mixture of fuel
and air into a tight space,
and then burning it.
LUKE: But they do it
in different ways.
ABHI: A car uses
a piston engine.
This is a piston engine
that's been cut into a half
so you can look into it.
A mixture of fuel and air
enters through these valves
into this metal cylinder.
It's compressed when the
piston pushes up onto it,
and then mixture is burned
through a spark plug,
causing the mixture to expand.
And the piston comes back down,
and this happens over and over
again.
There are multiple
pistons in a car,
and they're connected
through a series of linkages
to the wheel,
causing them to turn.
PROFESSOR: So we
changed a couple things,
changed out the music.
I'm still not a huge
fan of it, but I
thought it was a lot better
than what was there before.
We added a couple labels,
put in some stock footage.
I mean, to me, I
think the feel of it
changed a lot after having
the collaboration between four
or five of us.
And that happens with
every video, too.
I wanted to mention the five
words that you should never
say, which I often say, too--
but the notion of, we'll
fix it in post.
Like oh, the sound isn't
super great for this take,
but that's OK.
I'll fix it in post-production.
Thinking about
post is really good
to set you up for creating
as high quality materials
to work with as
you can possible.
So really try not to lean on
post-production and editing
as a space where you will
have a bunch of band-aids
to cover up material
that isn't as good.
You will save so,
so, so much time
doing just that extra take to
get the good audio than you
will if you tried to clean
it up in editing afterwards.
So don't say these words.
So we have to kill our darlings.
We have to figure out what
things are worth keeping
and what aren't.
What is the way that we
actually kill the pieces.
And that way is with the cut.
So the cut is going to be
the spaces in which we decide
to break the
footage that we have
and align it with something
new-- a transition.
Now this notion of seams
is an interesting one
when you're editing.
A seam is basically
like when you
notice that the location changes
or that the scene changes.
Being aware of
where your cuts are
and what your
scenes look like are
going to be important for the
overall feel of the video.
So in an earlier
lecture, I think
I'd mentioned storyboarding
is great because it gives you
a sense of what the visual
pacing of your video
is going to be.
When you're doing
cuts in editing,
watch through
sections of a portion
that you've edited--
maybe 30 seconds of it,
and basically see how
many seams there are
and if they're
really noticeable.
What I personally
like-- this is my taste,
and I think it's the
taste of most people--
is that I think
your seam should be
as deliberate and
clean as possible
so that they're not
very noticeable.
What you don't want
to end up happening
is someone to watch your video,
and notice every single time
you take a cut.
You don't want their reaction
to be, oh, she cut there.
Oh, she cut there too.
And for that reason, I
favor just clean cuts.
No funky transitions,
no ripple effects.
Do you guys know what
I'm talking about?
No spins.
I think we did one
push transition
that I fought against.
But that's my personal taste.
But in general, the cut should
be as hidden as possible,
I think.
Because that's not what
your video is about.
Your video is about the content.
It's not about the transitions
in between the scenes.
When you do clean cuts, though,
especially for these videos,
it has to be deliberate enough
to where it makes sense.
And I'll explain this further.
So in this example--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You can count up to 127.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: That is
the wrong example.
Never mind.
I'm not going to talk
about clean cuts.
Apparently I'm going to
talk about transitions.
So this is one transition
where something
that wasn't a clean cut
worked for us, I think.
Because we were being a little
tongue-in-cheek about the wipe.
The way we achieved
this is, George actually
loosened up his tripod.
And when Jamie was in Stata,
at the end of his shot,
he just flung the tripod up
so that the camera actually
swung up.
And then we used that to move
into the transition effect that
was in Final Cut.
It just makes the video
look a little more
clean and deliberate, I think.
Otherwise, you have
still frame, wipe up,
wipe down, to still frame.
It looks a little bit different.
What was I going to talk about?
So yes, sometimes it's
OK not to use clean cuts.
This is another example.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[TICKING]
[BEEPING]
PROFESSOR: All those were
clean cuts, by the way.
-Radiation is frightening.
At least, certain
types of it are.
My Geiger counter doesn't
go off near my mobile phone,
or the Wi-Fi router,
or my microwave.
That's because a
Geiger counter only
measures ionizing
radiation, that
is, radiation with enough energy
to rip electrons off atoms.
And it's measured in
units called sieverts.
If you're exposed to more
than two sieverts all at once,
you'll probably die
shortly after that.
But we're exposed to low
levels of ionizing radiation--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So that was a wipe.
But I don't feel like that's
super cheesy, because he only
uses it very sparingly.
Did you notice how
many cuts there were
in that 30 seconds of clip?
He must have cut 20 times.
But as a viewer, I'm not
noticing, oh, he cut there,
oh, he cut there, oh,
he cut there, right?
So that's what I mean by
keeping your seams hidden.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In a way,
it seems intuitive.
But when you're editing,
and you're looking,
and you're cringing
at your own speech,
it's a practice that
you might want to do.
You never cut in the
middle of a phrase,
or in the middle
of your talking.
Because that's really
jarring, like seeing your head
in one place, and
then seeing your head
in a slightly different place.
It's always really jarring.
But whenever he cut,
he cut to something
that was other than his face.
When he was walking through
with the Geiger counter,
he was cutting to different
angles of that same shot.
Or when he was just
talking to the camera,
he cut away from his face,
and then cut back to it.
So you don't see a little twitch
where he was saying one phrase
and he did another take, and
he was in a different spot.
It's something you don't
notice until you actually
get into the editing process.
And you see, whoa,
that's really weird.
But it's something
good to keep in mind.
So if you aren't going to
finish a two sentence phrase,
think of a way to
transition between that,
rather than just doing
a hard cut between them,
because it won't look clean.
PROFESSOR: I have
some examples of that,
that I was going to show you.
But that's a super,
super important point.
Yes, Joshua.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to say a sentence,
but I remember the plans video.
What did they have in
common, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So for that, we
are jumping ahead.
I have this one slide, and
then I'm going to get to it,
I promise.
So this is going
off of the whole
hide your seams type of thing.
I like to keep
labels really simple.
Sometimes you'll have
a need to label things.
Again, this may be a
matter of personal taste.
But I think the cleaner the
labels are-- no funky Word Art,
I think those other things
look a little amateurish.
If it's good content, it doesn't
need the frills, necessarily,
to be engaging.
So you were asking, cutting,
how do you do the thing
that Sari was saying?
For plants, we had
her really close up
for the beginning, right?
And then she goes, what do
all these chemical compounds
have in common?
And then we cut out to her
really wide, with her saying,
plants.
Right?
So that is an example of
making your cuts deliberate.
You want to cut
between two scenes that
look different enough, to where
the cut looks intentional.
So this is an example
from Jamie's video,
and I think this
is the right one.
[VIDEO  PLAYBACK]
-Even though we
think of computers
as super complicated high-tech
machines with very tiny parts,
they can also be huge,
wooden, and mechanical,
just like this computer here.
And even though they--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So right there,
I think in that take,
he messed up.
Or he took too long of a
pause in between the two words
that he was delivering.
So we wanted to
cut that pause out.
But it would have
been weird if we
just cut that
pause out, and then
didn't do anything
else to the footage.
So basically, he would have
been like, computers, blah blah
blah.
And then he would have
moved slightly to the left.
And then you would have
seen him keep talking.
Do you guys know what I mean?
I'll show you an example.
So to get around that, we had
his first part of the sentence
delivered the way we filmed it.
And then when we cut, we cut
to a digital zoom of him.
So he was a lot more close up.
And that's what Hank Green
does a lot in SciShow.
He cuts back and forth,
between a wide shot
and a close up shot, to make
the cuts a little less jarring.
I'll just show you the example.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What it is the most
awesome place in the world?
Seems like that would be
pretty much the most subjective
question ever.
But this week, scientists use
a set of objective criteria
to come up with a list of
the world's most biologically
important places.
There might be one near you.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: He also cuts at the
ends of phrases and sentences.
So it would feel a
little bit more awkward
if he was cutting in
between, this is my sentence.
And then he cut to
a close up, and I'm
going to keep
talking about this.
And then he didn't
cut, and he just
kept talking about
the next idea.
And then he cut back
to this wide shot.
So again, when you're filming
and you mess up, keep going.
But try to do as many continuous
thought takes as possible.
Because again, don't say,
I'm going to fix it in post.
Because sometimes you're going
to look at it, and be like,
there's no way around this.
It's OK if you can't get
an entire scene perfect.
But at least try to get
chunks of sentences,
or chunks of thoughts
continuously,
because that'll be a lot
easier to work with in post.
So this is the pitch that
I recorded for you guys.
And I made it this
way because I wanted
to show you that it does
look weird when you don't cut
to something different enough.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-When we think of
snot, we usually
think of the stuff
that oozes out
of us when we're sick, right?
[SNEEZE]
It's just more
gross bodily fluid
that we seem to excrete
for whatever reason.
But snot is more
than just the stuff
that hangs out of the noses
of most two-year-olds,
and some 20-year-olds.
It's filled with all of these
cells, that do everything
from fighting
infection, to keeping
your esophagus from
ripping up every time you
try to eat something.
[CHOKING]
And that junk actually can
keep stuff out of your body.
And then it knows what to
keep out, what to let in,
and when to do it all.
What?
That is so crazy.
Snot and mucus is so important
that your body makes a gallon.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: It's visually
very hiccupy, right?
Because I'm only moving
slightly to the left and right.
And I think it's appropriate
for webcam YouTube videos.
That's just kind
of the style of it.
You're centered,
which is also breaking
a rule of framing in thirds.
So stylistically, I think it's
more acceptable in YouTube
webcam videos.
But for these, it will
look out of place.
Because you have like a
very formalized script,
and it's going to jar with
a very amateurish style
of editing.
Does that make sense to people?
AUDIENCE: When you did
that, did you actually
have it in your
head that you were
going to cut to those
spots, or was it
just what you put together
after you had everything?
PROFESSOR: So I did that in
one long continuous take.
I just hit Photo Booth on Mac
and I said my whole thing.
And there were lots of spots
where I'd messed up in between.
So I did the style of
editing that I first
talked about, which is just
cutting out the bad bits.
So I wasn't
intentionally doing that.
But that's why the movements
are just a little off-kilter.
I'm not trying to
move or anything.
It's just that I
move when I talk.
But it reads a little
bit weird and jarring.
AUDIENCE: And you'd
recommend just leaving record
on for however long it takes?
Like in between scenes, maybe?
PROFESSOR: I personally have
a really hard time remembering
what I'm going to say.
So I would feel better,
when I was shooting,
if I knew that I only have to
say two or three sentences.
But when you record, always
record the preceding sentence,
and the sentence that
comes after the one
that you're trying to record.
Because your intonation
will sound different.
Otherwise, every single
sentence will sound like this.
It will sound like
you are talking
in the same style of sentence.
It will sound like
you were just reading
a bunch of bullet points.
So that's why, if
you're shooting scene 2,
shoot the last
sentence of scene 1,
and the second
sentence of scene 2.
Make sense?
And so this is also from
Walter Murch's book.
But this is sort of a
tongue-in-cheek thing.
Thing But he talks about what
makes a good cut, and the order
of priority.
A cut that maintains
the emotion of the scene
is something that's
really important.
Which sounds very strange.
But if you have, say,
a very dramatic scene,
with two people, like Sari and
I are getting into an argument,
right?
And we have the camera
that's focused on me,
and a camera that's
focused on her.
And you want to show both of us.
So actually, you would show
Sari getting all mad at me.
And then you'd show me
getting all mad at her.
Maybe you'd show her again.
If you did super rapid cuts
of her and me, back and forth,
back and forth,
back and forth, it's
going to read kind
of funny, right?
It'll read like Western parody.
You guys know what I mean?
But if you wanted to highlight
the gravitas of the situation,
you would cut from her
face to maybe a wide shot
of the two of us.
And you wouldn't make
the cuts as rapid.
Does that make sense to people?
So I think that's what
he means by maintaining
the emotion of a cut.
I think for the
purposes of your video,
the main thing will
be just making sure
that the cuts aren't happening
too rapidly, or too slowly.
I think you'll know.
You'll watch the
thing, and you'll
feel like something's
a little off kilter.
And if that's the
case, I would encourage
you to adjust how long
you're making the clips,
and how much dead space you're
leaving it between the clips.
This is a way to inject--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK, so this might
be we our weak point.
Or is it?
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So that's not a cut.
But that was a type of
zoom that is emotionally
appropriate for this
scene, because it's
trying to be funny.
But if you did that for you
talking about cargo ships
not sinking carrying
lots of people,
it would be totally
inappropriate, right?
The other thing he talks about
is, does it advance the story?
And I will show you
an example of this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-And all those bacteria
care about is staying alive.
Our intestine
actually helps them
do that, because the temperature
is warm and constant.
They're sheltered
from the environment.
And best of all, we
provide the food.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So does
anyone want to guess
how that particular
cut advanced the story?
Or did you notice
where the cut was?
AUDIENCE: Can you show it again?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So try to pay attention
to where the cut happens.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-All those bacteria care
about is staying alive.
Our intestine
actually helps them
do that, because the temperature
is warm and constant.
They're sheltered
from the environment.
And best of all, we
provide the food.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So there are
actually two cuts in this.
But the first cut
is of him walking.
He's like, and best of all.
And then it cuts to him
arriving to the place where
he was walking.
So in those five
seconds or so, the story
was about George walking
to the hood to do his demo.
That sounds like a dumb
story, but that's essentially
what the story of those
five seconds were.
So a cut that often
works is, if you're
doing like a walk and
talk, for instance,
and you're saying
blah blah blah.
Navy ships, people might sink.
And then you cut to the person
arriving at their station,
like where the boats
or whatever are.
Does that make sense to people?
AUDIENCE: So how do you
ensure that your voice doesn't
sound funny?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
like if your delivery
of the sentence
in one location is
too different from the other.
AUDIENCE: Do you remember how
you spoke it in the shoot?
PROFESSOR: So to shoot
that scene, for instance,
he would say, we shelter them.
And best of all--
we didn't cut there.
We made him finish the line,
when he's saying, best of all,
we provide the food.
And we took a complete cut
of him walking and saying
the whole line.
And then, when we shot the part
of him walking toward the hood,
it wasn't like we
said action, and he
said, we provide the food.
We said action, and he
says, and best of all
we provide the food.
So that's what I mean by,
say the lines that precede
and follow the line that you're
actually trying to capture.
AUDIENCE: And do multiple takes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And say
the line a little bit
differently each time.
Because maybe you'll
find that your third take
for the initial shot,
and your second take
for your second shot,
are the most cohesive.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
very good advice.
And as the directing partner
of whoever you're shooting,
this is the thing that you need
to do to help your partner.
If you notice that their
delivery in the second location
is a lot more subdued
and tired, which
is going to be the tendency for
most people, you can be like,
you said that the
beginning of that line
really energetically when
we were in that other place,
so you need to match that.
AUDIENCE: Even if you do
the take right, do it again.
It's really easy to say, oh
I did it right this time,
I'm done.
I memorized my lines.
But even if it's that struggle
to remember the last word
in the sentence,
it's worth it to get
another complete usable take
rather than be stuck with one.
PROFESSOR: And you're going
to have to work within reason.
Obviously you're not going
to do 100 takes of each scene
perfectly.
So this is up to your
discretion, and the amount
of time that you have.
But I would say, at least
try to get three good takes.
I lost my train of
thought completely,
but that was a very
important point.
Thank you.
And then the other
stuff is rhythm.
And this is what I mean by
if your cuts are too rapid.
Oh, I remembered what
I was going to say.
Sorry, I'm going all
over the place today.
So in the engines video,
that was the latest night
that we had worked.
I think I got home at 3:00
in the morning that day.
And at the end of the night,
obviously the two talents,
their energy levels
were super depleted.
And so that's what we
ended up re-shooting.
And that's what
re-shoots are for.
Even if you end up getting
all the shots that you need,
oftentimes you won't notice that
someone's delivery was really
different until you're
in the editing room,
and you cut everything together.
So that's why I wanted to
leave some room for you guys
have time to re-shoot
if you needed to.
I don't anticipate that
you're going to not
get shots that you need to get.
But that buffer room, we
always use it for Science
Out Loud, regardless of
how perfect the host is.
Just because stuff
like that happens.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This rock can absorb heat
from the sun during the day,
and then release that heat hours
later, after the sun has set.
This is fine when you're
dealing with rocks in the sun,
but unfortunately it also
happens with bodies of water
and toxins.
Rivers, lakes, streams,
and oceans are still
releasing contaminants
that we dumped
into them up to 100 years ago.
From 1947 to 1977, humans
dumped hundreds of thousands
of pounds of
polychlorinated biphenyls
into the Hudson River.
Those PCBs attach themselves to
sediment particles and settle
to the bottom.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So for that
video, we had a sense,
when we saw the rough cut, that
it was kind of a frantic video.
There's a lot of information
being thrown at you.
I'm not really following,
even though I've
helped her edit the script.
If I'm tuning out,
then the audience
is probably going to tune out.
So rhythmically,
the cuts maybe were
happening a little too fast.
And she's also, in real life,
a naturally fast talker.
We had to slow her down a lot.
But she's just an
animated person.
So we knew that the
tendency of this video
is going to just feel
super, super fast.
And if you are
naturally a fast talker,
this is something
to keep in mind,
that you can help the
pacing, and the franticness,
of maybe how you might read,
with how you cut the scenes.
So what we did instead was,
we allowed for a lot of time
in between her scenes to
fill with B-roll or music.
We tried to make the cuts not
happen as rapidly, basically.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This rock can absorb heat
from the sun during the day,
and then release it hours
later, after the sun has set.
This is fine when you're
dealing with rocks in the sun,
but unfortunately it also
happens with bodies of water
and toxins.
Rivers, lakes, streams,
and oceans are still
releasing contaminants
that we dumped
into them up to 100 years ago.
From 1947 to 1977, humans
dumped hundreds of thousands
of pounds of
polychlorinated biphenyls
into the Hudson River.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So again, it's a
super, super nuanced thing.
I think the music
helped with it a lot.
We tried to use very calm music.
We used a still of that
old photograph of people
cleaning up the Hudson
River, just to break up
how many times we were changing
back and forth between all
the locations.
Is this making sense to people?
Sometimes I feel
like I'm saying it.
And then I watch it, and I'm
like, that doesn't look super
different from the rough cut.
But it helped me
sleep that night.
And this is the other
stuff he talks about,
which is not as important.
But the eye trace,
like does it make
sense for the audience's focus
of interest within the frame?
So are you cutting
from something
where you're in the top
corner, to all of a sudden,
you're cutting to
something in the middle,
centered, to all of a sudden,
you're cutting to something
where you're on the left side?
Are you cutting so rapidly,
and changing your position,
to where it's not making
sense to the viewer?
The 2D plan on screen,
are you are you
consistent with the
stage line, basically?
So I don't think this is going
to be as relevant for you guys.
But if someone's
walking, for example,
and then you cut to a scene
where they're continuing
to walk, but they're in
the corner of the screen,
then it doesn't
make as much sense.
And then the 3D space of action.
If you have multiple
people in the same room,
or multiple objects, and
you cut from one angle
to another angle, make
sure the objects are still
the same relationship
to each other.
And the reason why
he lists this out
is, Walter Murch's theory
is, you should never
compromise emotion before
you would compromise
the eye trace with a cut.
So if a cut satisfies
the eye trace,
but it doesn't make
sense emotionally,
then you shouldn't do it.
Practically speaking, I
think what this translates
for you guys, is that
if something feels weird
when you see the rough cut of
your video, most of the time,
it will be because you
cut it in a weird place.
You either cut your
speech too short,
or you didn't cut to a wide
enough shot from a close up.
You are cutting too much, too
quickly, or not cutting enough.
Does that make sense?
I'm going to talk a
little bit about music,
and some of the Creative
Commons resources
that will be available to you,
if you want to use footage
that you don't have access to.
Before I go into
that, does anyone
have further questions
about editing?
Sari is good with Adobe, right?
You use Premier?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I used Premier.
I used iMovie before that,
so just give them those.
Final Cut Pro, I
haven't looked at it,
but professional editing
softwares usually
have some weird rules.
So, if that's what
you choose to use,
I can definitely go and
work in the computer lab
and figure it out.
PROFESSOR: So Building
26, I'll show you
at the end of class the website.
But I've reserved it for the
rest of this class period,
and it has all the software
on it if you want to use it.
I have used Final Cut Pro
and Final Cut Express.
I'm not super, super
good at it, though.
But in the remaining class
time, when you basically
have time to work
on your projects,
we will be around if you want to
schedule a certain time to work
on a particular problem
that you're having
in your editing software.
Just come talk to us.
All the tutorials for a
bunch of these software,
they're all listed
on the syllabus.
So when it comes to music,
it's a bit like lighting,
as Chris said.
First, do no harm.
So I would much prefer a
video that does not have music
to a video that has music
that is super distracting,
or an entirely different tone
from the video that you're
trying to convey.
So be careful with music.
But music is a really,
really great tool,
because I think it
establishes emotion
better than any other tool that
you have in your video kit.
That's my opinion.
I'll show you an example of it.
Do you guys remember the
video of Neil deGrasse Tyson
that I showed you
on the first day?
The 10 questions?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What is the most astounding
fact you can share with us
about the universe?
-The most astounding fact,
the most astounding fact,
is the knowledge
that the atoms that
comprise life on earth,
the atoms that make up
the human body, are traceable
to the crucibles that
cooked light elements into
heavy elements in their core.
Under extreme temperatures
and pressures,
these stars, the high
mass ones among them,
went unstable in
their later years.
They collapsed,
and then exploded,
scattering their enriched
guts across the galaxy.
Guts made of carbon
nitrogen, oxygen,
and all the fundamental
ingredients of life itself.
These ingredients become
part of gas clouds
that condense, collapse,
form the next generation
of solar systems, stars
with orbiting planets.
And those planets now have the
ingredients for life itself.
So that when I look
up at the night sky,
and I know that yes, we
are part of this universe,
we are in this universe.
But perhaps more important
than both of those facts,
is that the universe is in us.
When I reflect on
that fact, I look up.
Many people feel small,
because they're small,
and the universe is big.
But I feel big, because my
atoms came from those stars.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So this video
is effective for a couple
of different reasons.
You feel like you're
sitting there with him.
the person who's
sitting in the third chair,
watching an interview happen.
Say what you will about
Neil deGrasse Tyson,
but he's a very
engaging speaker.
And I think that this video
encapsulates the wonder
that he has for astrophysics.
I'm going to show you
another video that took
the audio from this interview.
And this user Max
Schlickenmeyer put together
a fan video that
highlights certain elements
of this experience in
a very different way.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What is the most astounding
fact you can share with us
about the universe?
-The most astounding fact.
The most astounding
fact is the knowledge
that the atoms that comprise
life on earth, the atoms that
make up the human body, are
traceable to the crucibles that
cooked light elements into
heavy elements in their core.
Under extreme temperatures
and pressures,
these stars, the high
mass ones among them,
went unstable in
their later years.
They collapsed,
and then exploded,
scattering their enriched
guts across the galaxy.
Guts made of carbon,
nitrogen, oxygen,
and all the fundamental
ingredients of life itself.
These ingredients become
part of gas clouds
that condense, collapse,
form the next generation
of solar systems, stars
with orbiting planets.
And those planets now have the
ingredients for life itself.
So that when I look
up at the night sky,
and I know that yes, we
are part of this universe,
we are in this universe.
But perhaps more important
than both of those
facts is that the
universe is in us.
When I reflect on
that fact, I look up.
Many people feel small,
because they're small
and the universe is big.
Because my atoms came
from those stars.
There's a level of connectivity.
That's really what
you want in life.
You want to feel connected,
want to feel relevant.
You want to feel like
you're a participant
in the goings-on of activities
and events around you.
That's precisely what we
are, just by being alive.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So, a very
different experience, right?
And did you recognize that song?
AUDIENCE: I don't,
but I thought it
was particularly
terrible when there
was a different set of words.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So we won't question
the scientific accuracy
of the video that he made.
And my mom watched it.
And she was like, Elizabeth,
this is super cheesy.
But it elicits emotion, right?
It's a very
different experience.
I also wanted to
point out, how would
it have felt if all
the images Max used
were bombarding you with
cut, cut, cut, cut, universe,
microbes, a tree of life, right?
Would that have been emotionally
appropriate for this video?
No.
So that's what I mean.
Visual pacing can change
the emotion of a video.
Music, when intentionally
done, can be very effective.
And when I look at seven or
eight Science Out Loud videos,
it usually takes me about a
week to get the music for it.
It's actually super
time-consuming.
I'll basically take you through
two or three episodes where
I looked for music, and
did a soundtrack for it,
and sort of the
workflow that I had,
and the reasoning behind
why I chose what I did.
Any comments so far, questions?
Everyone's OK?
So, the farts video.
George was very adamant
that he didn't want
this to read like dad humor.
So I wanted to put a
bunch of fart jokes in it.
He was like, Elizabeth,
I'm not doing that.
That's not who I am.
That's not me.
And I was like, OK,
I recognize that.
I recognize that I'm
a different person.
So he gave his
delivery very straight.
He gave it very dry.
He didn't make it
very outrageous.
This is farts, without music.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know what's more like
life than a box of chocolates?
Farts.
You really never know
what you're going to get.
Skunk, rotten eggs, garbage
dumpster-- the possibilities
are, unfortunately, endless.
But why do we fart, and how
does your body make so many
different smells?
The answer is fermentation.
This is a giant bioreactor.
It's also called a fermenter.
And in here, a fungus
known as brewer's yeast
is transforming water and
dead plants into beer.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So it feels
really weird, right?
And part of it is that
you don't necessarily
use the audio that you
record with the B-roll.
You usually put
music underneath.
So we didn't want it
to read as dad humor.
So we use a couple of
more serious tracks
at the beginning.
But it was a little bit weird,
because he is inherently
talking about a subject
that most sixth grade
boys, and myself, laugh at.
So the fact that we weren't
acknowledging the humor at all
whatsoever, and we're being
totally straight and deadpan
about it, it was a little
funny, unintentionally.
So we wanted to introduce
the humor through the music
that we used.
So I will play
you the rough cut.
Let me mirror this.
And this was a personal
decision of mine.
I'm sure that there are
people out there who would
have done it very differently.
And that's OK.
But let's play this.
Let's see.
I will show you a track
that went a little overboard
with the humor.
This is a track that
the editor found, called
Grandpa Is Scheming Again.
Oh, sorry, it's the wrong one.
Let me show you the
one before it, Ukulele.
This is ukulele comedy swing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know what's more like
life than a box of chocolates?
Farts.
You really never know
what you're going to get.
Skunk, rotten eggs,
garbage dumpster.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: But when I told
[INAUDIBLE], the editor,
I think we've got to inject
a little bit of humor
into it with the music.
I'm sorry.
There's too much tuba.
I think the comment
I wrote was, it
was in all caps, "LOL TOO MUCH."
But that's an example
of music. [LAUGHS]
So this is Grandpa
Is Scheming Again.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know what's more like
life than a box of chocolates?
Farts.
PROFESSOR: I felt that
this one had little bit
of potential, right?
-Skunk, rotten eggs.
PROFESSOR: But I thought
it was a little too
frantic for the beginning.
-The possibilities are,
unfortunately, endless.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: I'll show you
one more, Sharp Mind.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know what's more like
life than a box of chocolates?
PROFESSOR: We wanted
to highlight the wonder
of your digestive system.
So I said, [INAUDIBLE], find
me something that evokes
amazing wonder, curiosity.
-The possibilities are,
unfortunately, endless.
But why do we fart?
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: But it reminded
me a little bit too much
of Willy Wonka and Harry Potter,
which is why we ultimately
settled on--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You know what's more like a
life than a box of chocolates?
Farts.
You really never know
what you're going to get.
Skunk, rotten eggs, garbage
dumpster-- the possibilities
are, unfortunately, endless.
But why do we fart?
And how does your body make
so many different smells?
The answer is fermentation.
This is a giant bioreactor.
It's also called a fermenter.
And in here, a fungus
known as brewers yeast--
PROFESSOR: So it's
casual enough.
A super, super important
part about music
is that you don't want
it to be too distracting
from your audio.
-So you know that thing
where you eat food?
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: You should
stay away from music
that is super high
tempo, a lot of noise.
You want something
that's more uniform.
So there are a couple of
tracks where it was OK.
But then, every now
and then, there'd
be this random cymbal
hit, or a guitar riff
that would come out of nowhere.
And it would be
really, really evident
while the person was talking.
So that's very distracting.
Music, like everything
in post, I think,
should be as hidden as possible.
And by hidden, I
don't mean that you
shouldn't be able to hear it.
But you shouldn't be able
to notice it too much.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you cut
the scenes in accordance
with the beat of the song, or
can it be right in between?
PROFESSOR: No.
It can be in between.
And I was going to
talk about this later.
But all the examples I'm
going to show you do this.
Sometimes, if you want to end a
track before your actual video
ends-- say you're
talking and you want
some music in the background.
But then you cut
to a scene where
it's OK not to have music, or
you want to change the track,
you can do what's
called ducking.
Which is when you
take the audio,
and instead of just cutting
the audio cleanly and just
making the music
end all of a sudden,
in the editing software,
you can pull this cursor
down to where the
music slowly fades.
And it slowly becomes quiet.
You can duck in
and out of scenes.
So, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: If you have
music and B-roll,
that's a good way to help
with the pacing of B-roll,
because otherwise it's
kind of ambiguous.
Or it can kind of
ambiguous, how long you've
spent on a single object.
But music can help you,
if you're having trouble
finding the pacing of that.
Because then if you
have a music track,
you can time with the
beats. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'll show you an
example where we intentionally
lined up the beats of the music
to the visuals with B-roll,
actually.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Like when he
does this thing like this.
The editor did that
one [INAUDIBLE].
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So that was
more of a stylistic thing.
We wanted it to read like
bad-ass, like these skydivers
are going to go.
Yeah, that was a day
where we were getting
as much footage as possible, and
didn't end up using half of it.
Yeah, go big or go home, if
you have a skydiving license.
Go film, and go skydiving.
And shoot that.
This is an interesting example.
Because the computers one,
when I first saw the script--
I thought this is going to be
the hardest one to produce.
Because computer science
videos inherently
are just really hard to
do, because of the visuals.
And that's why there
aren't that many of them.
But this explanation, for
lack of a better term,
it just kept reading
incredibly boring.
Because it's essentially about
how you add in binary, right?
Which is not the most
riveting material.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Just like a light switch,
these switches have two states.
Either left and right, off
and on, or zero and one.
What's really cool here is
that instead of programming
this computer by writing
code, we program it
by physically
setting the position
of several different switches.
I'll set this computer to
count the number of balls
on the top tray by setting
the count switch to on.
The sum is given by this
bank of switches here.
We'll set the sum to zero
before we start counting.
PROFESSOR: I think Jamie's
doing a good job of hosting,
but it just gets
tedious, a little bit.
Because it's the same
thing over and over again.
You count the balls,
you set the switches.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So my initial
thought with this
was, I had a list of
brainstormed tracks.
And I was like, let's
go with something
boopy, sort of robotic
and electronic-y.
And this is what I mean
by be careful of how
distracting your music could be,
because this is what happened.
Universal Fluff Theory.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Just like a light switch,
these switches have two states.
Either left and right, off
and on, or zero and one.
What's really cool here is
that instead of programming
this computer by writing code--
PROFESSOR: It's just
a little much, right?
-by physically
setting the position--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And we fell into
a stereotype a little bit,
that a video about computers
has to be with electronic music.
And everything has
to be very robotic.
And the track that
[INAUDIBLE] ultimately
found, I really loved, because
it was very Zen, actually.
Which wasn't the
initial response
that I had to the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-has switches with a mechanical
input and mechanical output.
Just like a light switch,
these switches have two states.
Either left and right, off
and on, or zero and one.
What's really cool here is
that instead of programming
this computer by writing
code, we program it
by physically
setting the position
of several different switches.
I'll now set this
computer to count
the number of balls
in the top trade
by setting the
count switch to on.
The sum is given by this
bank of switches here.
We'll set the sum to zero
before we start counting.
Now let's start counting
by pressing this lever.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So I actually
personally like that track,
because there's
something about it that
makes the scene very inviting.
He seems really friendly.
You have something that's
as scary as programming
a computer, but then the
person is super friendly.
Jamie's just a really
friendly person in real life.
We were trying to make
computer programming as not
scary as possible.
And I think that having a track
that was a little more Zen,
it was a little quieter.
Someone was saying that
it's like a very mesmerizing
experience to watch it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] how do you
know if the volume of the song
is too much?
Or the beats themselves
are too much?
PROFESSOR: Again, a lot
of this is personal taste,
which is not the answer that
you guys probably want to hear.
But I would choose
what you like.
And hopefully I'm giving you
some pointers as to maybe
what works, and what
doesn't, as well.
But that's also where the
other three people that you'll
have looking at
your rough cuts will
come in handy, quite a bit.
You'll have the opinions of
at least five or six people.
Which, ideally you'd have more.
But that would give
you some sense.
And this sounds dumb,
but if you can't clearly
make out what the
person is saying
because the music is too
loud or too distracting,
then don't use it.
But sometimes you
don't know, and that's
why you ask other people.
The last example I
wanted to show you--
did anyone have
questions besides that?
Everyone's good?
So the last example I wanted
to show you was of Anastasia.
Now, I was very conscious
of who she was as a person
when we were making this
video, because she was just
this very bubbly, blonde girl.
But she does intense,
legit systems biology.
And I didn't want to undermine
her intelligence or her persona
as this very
inspiring STEM figure
by playing into the ditzy trope.
So at first, I was putting
really hard rock music
into her video to fight this.
She's doing intense
science, give that vibe.
It did not work for
obvious reasons, now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: And what I realized
was that Anastasia as a person
is super bubbly.
And she loves science.
And that doesn't
undermine her abilities
as a scientist, or
her authority at all.
And that if we
fought that too much,
it read really weird, because
that's just not who she is.
So we did go with a track that
was more capturing the wonder
that she had for plants.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Paclitaxel is a compound
that can treat cancer.
Salicylic acid reduces
headaches and fevers.
Carotenoids can turn
your skin orange.
And miraculin changes
your sense of taste.
What do all of these awesome
compounds have in common?
They all come from plants.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So music is really
good for evoking emotion,
establishing things
like wonder, creepiness.
This is an example of one.
And it can also help if you just
have some really funky audio
going on from the environment
that you're filming in.
I hate to say this,
but sometimes it
can be a little bit of
a Band-Aid to cover up
weird background noise.
When we were shooting in the
brewery for George's video
with all the vats, it was
just super noisy in there.
And there's nothing that
we could do about it.
So he just talked really
loud, and we put in the track.
And I think it helps distract
from that a little bit.
But again, don't say
we'll fix it in post.
Last example, I lied
about the other one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-These patterns can
seem pretty complicated.
Some people even think octopuses
use patterns like these
to mesmerize their prey.
But these intricate displays
emerge on the squid skin
even after it's been
disconnected from the brain.
So what's going on?
First I wanted to measure
how the chromatophores--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So when
the music changes,
we ducked from the
previous track.
This is what I
was talking about.
Hopefully it's not super
jarring or obvious to you
that we were changing music
tracks in the background,
because we ducked one
out and ducked one in.
But the second track, where
the question mark comes,
I liked it because
it was sort of eerie.
And it emphasizes,
this is super weird
that the squid skin does that.
How exactly does it do it?
And it's a way that we implied
that without her explicitly
saying it in the script.
So, when a lot of you
guys end your scripts,
or have a line in there
that's like, this is awesome.
Or, and that's how you do that.
You don't have to
say that explicitly.
Because a lot of the time,
the music can do that for you.
All right.
So I talked a lot about what
kind of music you should use,
and you are probably
wondering, well,
where am I going
to get this music?
So I wanted to talk a little bit
about Creative Commons, which
is the license that
MIT usually uses.
It's what OpenCourseWare uses.
It's what Science Out Loud uses.
And basically, it's a type
of license or copyright.
And in particular, we use CC
BY-NC-SA, which I will explain,
which allows you to freely
share and adapt materials.
So because this class,
and this lecture,
is being recorded
under Creative Commons,
under this license if someone
watches this video later on,
and they want to take a
portion of this lecture,
and remix it into a video
about best practices of music,
they can do it.
And I won't sue them.
Because it's totally allowed.
And I want them to take
the material and remix it,
as long as they attribute.
And this is true of any music
that you use for your videos.
So if you go and search
for Creative Commons music,
you will find a
ton of resources.
I've listed the websites
that we have personally
used in the day 7
lecture on the syllabus.
Things like ccMixter,
Jamendo-- thanks to Billy,
we know about that one
now-- Free Music Archive.
Unfortunately music is
not organized online
in the best way possible.
So a lot of it is sitting
and wading through tracks,
and just listening
to a bunch of them.
And that's why it's
so time consuming.
But a quick note about
Creative Commons.
So your videos will be
released under this license,
meaning that the
music that you use,
and any stock footage or
video that you find online,
has to also be Creative Commons.
And if you have
trouble with this,
let me know,
because I have dealt
with issues like that a lot.
But basically, when you
upload your final projects
onto YouTube, it's totally fine
for you to use other music,
as long as, in the description,
you say we used this track.
Here's a link to
the original site.
This is the person who made it.
That's just best
practices in general.
Ideally, you would cite images
that you use in your video
itself.
You'll notice that Science
Out Loud doesn't annotate
with citations on the
actual videos themselves,
because that was a
stylistic decision of ours.
But we put all the citations
in our YouTube descriptions.
And everywhere the
video is online for us,
we put all of the citations.
So for our license,
it means that
is free to share and adapt, as
long as you attribute, and it's
not used for
commercial purposes,
and that you're releasing your
work under the same terms.
So if someone took this lecture
and then used a portion of it
to record a lecture
for The Great Courses,
for instance, which
you have to pay to use,
because it's a commercial
company, that's not allowed.
On the syllabus, you'll also
find links to stock music.
Good music costs usually
around $30 to $40 per track.
So sometimes, we use
things like PremiumBeat,
which was where all the
tracks for the examples
I showed you were found.
And so sometimes,
if you just can't
find something that's
free, it's really worth,
I think, the money to
do music the right way.
And then one more
note about video.
So maybe you have the
Hudson River, for example.
We obviously couldn't
film at the Hudson River.
So I found a picture of it
on the Internet Archive,
which is where you can find
a lot of videos, music.
They're all under
Creative Commons.
I'll put links to all
this in the syllabus,
and I'll post something
on Tumblr later today
that consolidates
all these resources.
For biology videos, the
NIH has a lot, actually,
under Creative Commons.
A lot of open
source publications,
you can use their figures,
as long as you cite.
And Wikipedia, all
of those images
are released under
Creative Commons.
The US government websites
are actually really,
really great resources,
because they release everything
under public domain.
So it's not even
Creative Commons.
You can just use
whatever you want.
NASA has awesome footage.
NIH, I'm trying to
think of others.
But that's actually
a go-to place for me
if I'm searching for footage
that we just can't shoot.
So that's all I had
planned for today.
Does anyone have
questions off the bat?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about working with the music
that you had.
I've been doing
stock music before.
Some of them are like a
one [INAUDIBLE] thing,
and some are
repetitive [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it loops
the same tune over and over.
AUDIENCE: Do you use those?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The looped ones are nice for
us, because sometimes the longer
ones are like big orchestral
arrangements that take awhile
to get to the point of the song.
Whereas, for a lot of
the music, you just
want something
that's present, that
establishes a general
sound and atmosphere.
But you're not looking for
a Mozart composition, right?
You just want something to fill
in the background a little bit.
So having something
that's looped
is actually preferred for us.
AUDIENCE: Have you done a video
where there was [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, some
of our earlier videos
don't have as much music.
And part of it was that I
wasn't savvy enough to do it.
And I watch some of them now.
I'm like, man, this video
just feels super long.
And it seems like they're
talking for a long time.
And I think part of it's
because of the music.
You don't need music
everywhere, though.
And like I said, during the
presentation, first do no harm.
So sometimes, if you just
can't find music for it,
leave it out.
I'm trying to
think of an example
where we said we specifically
do not want music here.
And I can't come up with
any off the top of my head.
But maybe after class, I
can look for something.
AUDIENCE: Elizabeth, can
you talk a little bit
about how the next couple
days are going to work?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Thank you for the reminder.
So this is it for formal
lectures between now
and next Thursday, which is when
the final presentations will
be.
You will have
class time to work.
So we are going to pair you
up, or put you into groups
for filming partners.
And you will have class
time tomorrow, the day
after, and Friday to work.
We will have a screening of
the rough cuts next Tuesday.
So that gives you the weekend
to edit together the footage
that you shoot this week.
We'll screen
everyone's rough cuts.
We'll also assign
you editing partners.
And I'll tell you more about
this on Tuesday as well.
But you'll watch the videos.
And we have a video annotation
software that you can use.
So you'll make comments
on at least two
or three other people's
videos during class time.
And then you'll have
until Thursday, where we
don't have normal class time.
Our final screening is going
to be in Simmons Hall at 6:30
instead of at 1:00 PM.
It'll be like a
red carpet event.
But you'll have all day that
day to finish whatever you need.
I wouldn't wait until 6:00 PM
to have your video finished.
But if it comes down to that,
it's not like we have to know.
Yeah, so it's pretty
much work time from here.
The teaching staff will
be available to help you.
So it's basically like
office hours from here
on out, except for the rough
cut screening next Tuesday.
And if you have specific
questions on editing,
we'll send out a
Google spreadsheet
so you can sign up
for specific people,
or if you have certain
requests to go over things.
AUDIENCE: Or, if it's in the
evening and you're editing,
and you find a problem that you
just don't know how to solve,
feel free to email us.
Shoot out an email before
you start tackling it
for two to four hours.
Because if it's
a simple solution
that we can relate over email,
that'll save you so much
time and frustration.
PROFESSOR: And I'll send
out an email to where
everyone's emails are CC'd.
You can ask your peers
questions as well,
because I'm sure you're going to
run into very similar problems
once you start
editing and shooting.
So use each other as
a resource as well.
And honestly, I can't feign
expertise over any of this.
So oftentimes, I just Google.
Why won't my clip snap
to the previous one?
But, I will send out
shooting assignments.
Actually, I have them with me.
AUDIENCE: Elizabeth,
we'll be in here
during class time
as a home base.
So if you have any
questions, and you need help,
we'll be physically in this
room for you to swing by.
You don't have to come
into this room physically.
You can use the entire class
time to be out and about.
But just so that you
know that you can,
at any point, during that
1:00 to 4:00 time frame.
If you need help with anything,
I will as much as I physically
can be--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I will
definitely be here.
AUDIENCE: They will
definitely be in this room,
to be here if you want
physical help with anything.
And if you want to,
just to make sure,
you can feel free to email a
specific point person to say,
I am coming in at
this time for sure.
If you know ahead of time that
you need help with something,
just so that we know
we should reserve time
to deal with this
issue with you.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And if you need Chris's help
or Natalie's help on anything,
just email them directly.
Because they are available,
although they're a little bit
busy.
So as long as they have
enough of a heads up,
we can make that work.
I did want to let you
guys know about 26 139.
Do guys know where the
801 TEAL classrooms are?
Oh, I guess you guys would know.
It is basically in that
building on the first floor,
actually, right next to us.
It says Building 26.
It's on the first floor.
You need key card access.
You just swipe your MIT ID.
And I have that room reserved
every day during class time
until the final day.
So if you want to use
their software, you can.
I also have nicer headphones if
anyone needs to borrow those.
I think everyone has a kit.
I feel like I'm
forgetting something.
Oh, I'm forgetting to tell
you the shooting assignments.
So David and Joshua, we'll
put you guys together.
[? Yulia, ?] Kenneth, and
Paul, you guys will be a group.
And then Andrea and Nathan, you
guys will be shooting partners.
AUDIENCE: That wasn't random.
We really tried
to think about who
you are, and your
scripts, and all of that.
Because sometimes, if
you have a great partner
that can really
complement you, that
can really help your project.
We really did put a
fair amount of thought
into those partnerships.
It's not just like a
random division of labor.
PROFESSOR: If you have
any issues during filming
whatsoever, about anything, if
you can't get into a location,
if you need help
clearing something,
if you're not sure something
is allowed to be filmed,
if things are just
not going well,
if Murphy's Law is
happening, email me.
Or come find me during class.
Or email any of us.
We are definitely here to help
you guys for the home stretch.
AUDIENCE: And I think
I've showed this to you,
but when you're walking
to the bathroom,
there's a big sign that
says communication lab.
That's my office.
So if ever during
normal business hours,
outside from class
time, you literally
need help with anything,
that is where I am.
So you can always knock and
interrupt anything, and just
say, I need help with
something, and it'll be fine.
PROFESSOR: And my office is a
little far away from campus.
But if you want to
meet in the morning,
or sometime outside of class,
if you just email me ahead
of time, I can definitely
meet with you guys.
AUDIENCE: And one last thing is
the "kill your darlings" thing.
As someone who has been
writing for quite a long time,
and who has edited
people professionally,
it's really hard.
The more you get
invested in this,
the harder it is to
be able to do that.
And that's when as
a partner, that's
a great point, when you're
not emotionally connected
to the work.
This is just advice.
Instead of pointing out
that it's not working,
maybe think about framing some
questions for your partner,
to help them realize
that this isn't working.
And that's a really great job
you have as a partner, to help
your colleague realize
that this piece is awesome,
it's really cool,
but it doesn't work.
And that can be really,
really hard feedback.
So thinking about how
to help your partner
see that sometimes is a
really important task.
PROFESSOR: And
part of your grade
will come from how great
of a partner you are.
So ha ha, you have to do it.
I don't remember the
exact percentages,
but 60% of the grade comes
from your writing and hosting.
40% of it comes
from the producing
that you do for your partner.
And for the group of three,
figure it out how you want.
But I was thinking
one person does
for person 2 which
does for person 3 which
does for person 1.
Does anyone have
questions, concerns?
AUDIENCE: You say the
assignment's on the quality.
So what is that [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: She means just
that these are your partners
to do the project.
The people that
she just mentioned
are your partners for
producing your project.
It's a phrase that I'm
sure you use [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sorry.
And also, don't feel limited to
only working during class time,
if you and your partner would
rather meet in the morning.
Or if you want to
just shoot some stuff
on your own, like B-roll,
that's totally fine.
I will put this link
up on the Tumblr.
And I'll email it out
to you guys today, too.
I would love it if sometime,
before the end of the weekend,
you filled out this super,
super short midpoint survey,
just to give us a
good idea of what
is working best for you all.
What type of feedback
is working best?
Because I want to make sure
that for the last week,
it's going to be a
lot of project time.
So I just want to make
sure that the time is
as valuable to you as possible.
So it's really quick.
It's super painless.
It's just telling me what your
favorite day was, basically.
So I'll send out a
link to you guys.
Just any time between now and
the weekend would be awesome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, for
most of the videos, we
have at least two or three.
I think we have around
three in all of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I don't have
an algorithm for you,
unfortunately.
A lot of it is just
what feels right to me.
AUDIENCE: And you can
ask for second opinions.
PROFESSOR: Of course.
AUDIENCE: This is a great
time to ask your group,
or other people in the class.
Or come in and ask us, too.
If it's like, I
found this music,
I'm not sure how
I feel about it.
How do you guys feel about it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And if you're in the
editing room on Friday
during class time, and
you want us to look at it,
just send me an email
and be like, hey,
can you meet me in 26 at 2
o'clock to help me with this?
And I will do it.
So, at the beginning it's funny.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-A skunk, rotten eggs, garbage
dumpster-- the possibilities
are, unfortunately, endless.
PROFESSOR: And he's talking
about how funny it is.
-Break food down to get energy.
But your main byproducts are
carbon dioxide and water,
and yeast's main byproducts
are carbon dioxide and alcohol.
That's how this stuff
gets to be beer.
And here's where
things get weird.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: So that's a
new break in thought.
It was a logical
transition point for us,
because he opens with farts
are like a box of chocolates.
But this is the part
where you're starting
to really get into the science.
And he wants to highlight
the misconception of,
the thing that you thought
was funny is actually really
weird and super interesting.
So we introduced this track that
I felt conveyed that sense of,
this is weird.
There's something
interesting about this.
But yeah, unfortunately,
I don't have a recipe.
I think once you start
doing it on your own,
you're going to
get a sense of it.
And once you start seeing
other people's projects,
you'll get a sense of it.
AUDIENCE: There's
always the mom test.
My mom, I feel like she's
so like that-- oh, I
don't understand, what
are you doing with this?
I can't hear.
I feel like my mom is like,
if I can show it to her,
and she'll be like, oh,
I can hear everything,
and your music's
not distracting me.
Or, can you make it louder,
honey, I can't hear that part.
If you have someone in your
life who plays that role,
that's a great person
to check in with.
PROFESSOR: I'm happy to be
that person for you guys.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
louder on this part?
PROFESSOR: But that's why audio
is so important to get right
when you're producing.
Because if you record too
soft, there's only so much
you can do in the editing.
And if you record
too loud, you're
going to peak the microphone.
And it's going to
sound really scratchy.
So when you're filming someone,
watch a take or two, just
to make sure that the audio's
sounding clean and OK.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have the GoPros here,
or is that somewhere else?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I have
them in my office.
I can actually go
there after class
right now, if you're
planning on using them
before tomorrow's class.
AUDIENCE: Probably Thursday.
PROFESSOR: Thursday?
OK, then I'll just bring them
with me to class tomorrow,
and I'll leave them
in Jamie's office.
They've never been
opened before.
AUDIENCE: What's that?
PROFESSOR: They've never
been opened before.
They're brand new,
just for you guys.
AUDIENCE: And if you need
access to something that's
In my office, and there's a
code, and if you email me,
and I'm not there, don't
steal anything, obviously.
But if you need access
and I'm not around,
I can give you the code
to get into that room.
PROFESSOR: You guys
can come to my office,
but it's all the way
out in Tech Square.
So I would imagine most
people wouldn't want to.
AUDIENCE: And if you see lots of
strange students in my office,
that's just probably my fellows.
So, say hey.
PROFESSOR: Does anyone
have certain props
that they want to use?
Does anyone need a hand cart?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'll
need simple things,
like a wire that I can bend.
So maybe a couple, if it
doesn't work out the first time.
PROFESSOR: So for
those props, I'm
going to have you guys get them.
For bigger things,
like a hand cart,
or if you need another tripod,
or if you need a light kit,
or something.
AUDIENCE: I think that
may be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If it's simple,
like under $20, I'm
going to have you guys go ahead
and coordinate that, though.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
What font is that?
PROFESSOR: What font is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Actually, that font
was very, very intentional.
For a while, I tried
to make my own font.
But then I was
like, that's silly,
just use an existing one.
I can't remember
what the name of it
is off the top of my head.
But we use it to brand
Science Out Loud.
But I can send it to
you once I find out.
I think it's a Google
Font, actually.
AUDIENCE: The O's are different,
and the H's are different.
PROFESSOR: Oh, no,
that's just stuff I drew.
But I think he's talking
about for the text font.
I think it's actually Amatic SC.
It's a Google font.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I will
put it on the Tumblr.
I've got to remember
to do that, though.
AUDIENCE: So how
exactly do you do
that, like draw something on the
computer or would [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I don't have any
of the examples with me,
but I just draw on a piece
of paper with Sharpie.
And that's how I do all
these presentations, too.
So for day 9, I did
this at the airport.
This is basically all it is.
And then I take a
picture with my iPhone.
And then I blow out the
exposure in Keynote.
It's nothing fancy.
And Sari knows how to animate
the things in After Effects.
But basically you
take a still image,
and you draw a path
for the computer
to wiggle it around for you.
AUDIENCE: Before I knew how
to animate in After Effects,
you can just use Illustrator,
which is a really good vector
art program.
Do you have a tablet?
PROFESSOR: I have
10 Wacom tablets,
in case anyone
wants to use them.
AUDIENCE: The best way to
translate your handwriting
to digitally, so if you
want your handwriting
to just be digital,
then you open up
a file in Illustrator that's
the same size of your screen,
or your video, so, 1928 by 800.
Or something like that.
And you just draw
in it, and you can
change the width of your lines.
You can redo the
shapes that you do,
because it's just a
readable document.
And then you can export
that as an image file.
It'll be the exact same
size as your video clips,
when you've edited it.
And you can make backgrounds
transparent then too.
So you can just have
your vector art.
PROFESSOR: You don't have
to make it black and white.
I just tend to do it
because it's easier for me.
But if you're trying to
draw the PDL or something,
she's much better at that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You what?
AUDIENCE: I thought
that was your font.
PROFESSOR: Oh really?
No, I made it at the airport.
AUDIENCE: So how can you
avoid giving [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, I will
show you exactly what
I did for this slide.
So I said, I'm going
to insert this image.
And this is Keynote.
I think you can
do in PowerPoint.
You can definitely
do it in Photoshop.
This is me just being
newb extraordinaire.
I went to Image, and
first I flipped it.
And I basically
adjusted the levels,
so I blew out the
background first.
And then I inverted it.
I'm basically taking all
the whites to the extreme.
Of course it's not working now.
I promise it does work.
OK, let's try this again.
Sometimes it's finicky.
Does anyone have other
questions while I
try to get this to work?
I'm going to try a
different picture.
AUDIENCE: It makes us all
feel better that it's not
[INAUDIBLE].
For me, it makes me feel better.
PROFESSOR: No, it is.
I'll go with this one.
And I'm sure there is a
very streamlined way that
kills fewer trees.
Oh my goodness, I don't
know why it's not working.
So if you're doing a black
image on a white background,
this is all you would do.
This is not clearing
the background,
so the background is
going to be black.
So you would have to do
what Sari's talking about
as far as basically
creating a vector art that
has a transparent background.
AUDIENCE: And it's really easy.
The hardest part is
getting used to the tablet,
because it's weird writing, and
seeing your writing up here,
somewhere else than
what's on the page.
PROFESSOR: Ha, I got it.
That is all I did.
And I cropped it.
AUDIENCE: I've done stuff
like this in PowerPoint.
You could do it just as
easily in PowerPoint, yeah.
They give you cool stuff
to make it look like teeth,
or there's all these cool--
and then just black and white.
They're really easy.
But that looks really cool.
PROFESSOR: But for animations,
labels, overlay in general,
I think simple is
better because clarity
is most important for
graphics, and anything
that's not the video.
The video itself also
needs to be clear too.
Clarity is very important.
AUDIENCE: Can we use the
Wacoms in your office
on our own computers, or do we
have to use that in the lab?
PROFESSOR: No,
they're are my office.
It's a USB hookup.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And
they're kind of old.
Yeah, they're not
the newest kind.
I think they're five
or six years old.
But I have a bunch of them.
I didn't bring them with
me because I wasn't sure
if people would be
interested in them.
But yes, please take them,
because they're just sitting
in a cabinet in my office.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If you guys want
them tonight, I'm
happy to go over
and get them now.
But I can also just bring
them to class tomorrow.
AUDIENCE: Can you
overlay the video
with animations in iMovie
so I can [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
iMovie is great,
because there's a very
low learning curve.
And so, if you're doing
simpler things like cutting out
the bad bits, people might say
iMovie is a newb thing to use.
But I use it for
really simple videos
that I don't need to do
a whole lot of work with.
Unfortunately, for
the animations,
I don't think it's
possible, and that you
would need to use something
like After Effects.
Or you would need to use
Final Cut to incorporate it.
AUDIENCE: So the
problem with iMovie
is because it's
so simple, it only
has one video track
and one audio track.
And in order to
overlay an animation,
you need at least two
video tracks, which
comes in Final Cut or Premier.
PROFESSOR: Something that
you can do with iMovie,
I'm not sure if some of
you guys would do this--
but say you are standing in the
side of the frame like this.
And you want another movie
to play on the inside.
You can do that in iMovie.
You can do an inset.
And that's something that's
pretty straightforward to do.
AUDIENCE: And you can have
words show up over you.
It's very easy to do in iMovie.
If it's not an
animation, but just
a word that you
want next to you,
that's really easy to do,
and have text show up.
AUDIENCE: Or an image.
That would be [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I'll show
you the video later
because I can't
find it right now.
You can do insets, really
basic things on iMovie.
But animations, you can't.
What you could do, is you could
work with Sari in After Effects
to get the video clip where
you want the animation,
and export it as its own file.
And then import it into iMovie.
So you're basically using
a polished animation.
That way, if you
want to keep working
in iMovie for the rest of
your project, you can do that.
AUDIENCE: And we need to
go to the [INAUDIBLE] lab
to use the After Effects?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
because they only
are in installed
computers on campus.
And it's literally
in that building.
AUDIENCE: And if you end
up wanting to work at home,
it takes usually an hour, but
you can install all the Adobe
software for free for a month.
And they don't
automatically charge you,
because you don't put in credit
card information, or anything.
You just sign up with
an email address.
And then you can download
them for a month trial.
Did teams want to spend the
last little bit on a little game
plan time?
PROFESSOR: Don't forget,
a daily blog for today.
I think I put this in the email.
The syllabus is updated
with all the assignments.
Basically, from
now until the end,
it's just the video
itself that's due.
And daily blogs are just for
today and the rough screening
day.
But if you take behind
the scenes pictures, which
I love to do, behind
the scenes stuff,
feel free to upload
that to the Tumblr.
AUDIENCE: So there's no shot
list, or anything like that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The scripts, I think everyone
has sent me, for the most
part, updated scripts.
The shot list and all that,
it's really for your benefit.
I want you to feel as
ready as possible to shoot.
Actually, I would like you
to upload the shot list.
But I won't set a
due date for it.
I'll change the
syllabus with that.
But do upload your shot list.
I would like to see it up
there by Thursday, at least.
Because if you're not thinking
about shooting by then--
does that sound OK to everyone?
Break, go team.
Yay, people.
It'll be awesome.
I can't wait to see your videos.